bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
championnat du monde 2016 entre le
tenant du titre magnus carsen et sergei
car yakine donc le russe le norvégien
n'ont qu'à les blancs dans la première
partie le match a lieu donc à new york
c'est en 12 parties en cas d'égalité il
y aura bien sûr un match de départage en
partie rapide on n'en est pas là dans la
première partie du match de carling va
démarrer avec les blancs et normalement
je crois bien que au milieu de tournoi
il y aura un version des couleurs ce qui
est normal ça permet d'avoir une équité
maximale donc ici on est parti dans
cette dans ce championnat du monde 2016
qui est très attendu car ça ne démarre
avec les blancs tout de suite on rentre
dans le vif du sujet avec donc des
quatre coups du tout madame cariat qui
ne répondent par le très souple
cavaliers psy ce qui est assez standard
comme réponse extrêmement souple on
pourra ensuite transposé dans énormément
d'ouverture possible et là tout de suite
surprise fou g5 dans la position la
fameuse variante 39 ski alors vous
pourrez avoir une analyse de cette
ouverture dans les leçons diagonale tv
sur les ouvertures il ya il ya une
émission consacrée cette ouverture il ya
d'autres émissions consacrées à trompe
ce qu'il ya des partis qui ont été
analysés il faut il faut regarder
lesquels je peux pas vous dire là tout
de suite mais c'est pas une ouverture
considérée comme une ligne de premier
ordre si une ligne considérée comme une
variante secondaire mais qui a du venin
parce que l'idée des blancs c'est de
faire la pression donc on le voit tout
de suite sur ce cavalier menace de
prendre et de d'avoir des pions au noir
qui se doublerait haut sur l'a46 et si
les blancs jouent le coup justement ici
e6 pour pouvoir reprendre de la dame on
peut tout de suite joué que 4 menaçant
1,5 et le cavalier qui est cloué est
attaqué par le pion et les bleus ont des
problèmes
pas encore s'en sortir mais ça pose du
coup par contre énormément de problèmes
positionnelle qu'il faut résoudre et qui
sont pas simples alors c'est vraiment
dans le style de carsen jouer ce type
d'ouverture c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant de s'y appesantir un petit
peu dans un match aussi court 24 parties
je vous rappelle les anciens championnat
du monde notamment kasparov et karpov
aussi ou encore si on ne pouvait
remonter aussi même à fisher spassky
c'était au moins 24 parties quand
c'était pas plus puisque c'était le
premier en six victoires en pro fischer
allez les
les championnats du monde sont devenus
plus cours depuis le fameux kasparov
kramnik de l'an 2000 qui était un match
là aussi en 12 parties est-ce qu'ils
vont garder les mêmes ouverture sous
deux parties je sais pas mais en tout
cas tout de suite
carson rentrent dans son style justement
ils préfèrent les variantes secondaire
pour entrer dans des dépositions
atypique dans les qualifiés valoir son
sens se positionner à l'exceptionnel et
sa très grande technique en finale voilà
donc c'est vraiment dans le style de
carsen c'est lui qui donne le ton
d'entrée avec ce fameux coup ici un fou
j'ai sec donc dé 5,2 car yakine coût
normal coup logique
un des coups classiques dans cette
ouverture la planète possibilité je vous
laisse étudier cette ouverture par
ailleurs on va pas regarder la théorie
ici et bien sûr eu 3 est la poker s'est
tranquillement e3 maintenant que le fou
est sorti d'un fou c'est un gsm on joue
trois en étant serein parce que on a mis
le fou derrière les pions ici la voilà
donc il est en jeu et avec les pions on
contrôle bien les cases noires dans son
propre camp donc on est tranquille et on
peut maintenant faire jouer le fou de
casse marche c'est 5 de carnitine très
agressif il se laisse pas raconter
l'histoire ici car yakine c5
ils jouent pas passif il aurait pu jouer
aux 6 pour entrer dans une sorte de
gambie dames où les blancs ou rouges et
5 ça se fait aussi mais non ils
préfèrent jouer beaucoup plus agressif
ce sur quoi il se heurte au coût de cars
scène qui est bien sûr fou pranger celle
qui est l'idée la trompeuse qui est
après purpan g5 ça y est qui on croyait
réussissent par l'oncfs problème 6.6 les
noirs on ait pu renouveler 7 et 6 voilà
c'est un peu le thème ici et on échange
de quoi belle et noir ont quand même si
la paire de phu yên petite faiblesse la
met
la paire de fou qui peut s'avérer
dangereuse si les blancs font pas
attention
il a tout de suite décision très très
carsen ça puis on prend ces scènes voilà
ça c'est intéressant pour le norvégien
ils menacent pourquoi pas de garder un
pion de plus parce que vous allez
prendre ce pion l'on peut le prendre
tout de suite par damas cinq échecs mais
ça permet aux blancs de sortir leurs
pièces ont tous joué dam des deux
projets auxquels ces trois en tout cas
des deux et après la présence et 5 et
bien on continue à se développer
et si les noirs ne reprennent pas on
pourrait envisager avec les blancs de le
tenir ce pion aussi des 4 as n est au
juste ces trois tout simplement prise
prises et ça tient et les noirs un pion
de moins donc c'est pas simple attention
cavalli c6 tranquillou des jacaré acquis
dans le classicisme et déjà ils
contrôlent la classe b 4 on peut pas
jouer b4 tout de suite c'est normal
comme coup l'écart scène il continue il
faut des cinq héros ce qui menace pas
ici justement de pouvoir jouer b4 quand
même et de garder son pion de plus c'est
une possibilité qu'il faut un qu'il faut
envisager ces eaux noires de jouer mais
alors imaginons ici que les noirs jouent
base le coup la partie très bien aussi
ce là car ce n a pas joué là la bécade
il aurait pu envisager
regardez on peut envisager ici b4
maintenant qui est vraiment dans l'idéal
on appris en csn pourquoi pas s'est
gardé le pion lequel ne peut pas
reprendre puisqu'il est cloué par le fou
est maintenant si les noirs jouent le
coup k r tout à fait bompassenc
simplement aux joues c3 et primes
ici par exemple la prise ou on peut
jouer aussi soudé c'est pourquoi pas
mais la prise d'eau est bon tout
simplement on prend pour des quatre ici
reprise est là on peut jouer un coup par
exemple comme un fou 17 pour des clous
et le cavalier apparaît tout à fait
logique et est bien le problème c'est
que les blancs le temps maintenant
d'aller protégés et ceux qui auront par
exemple par dame dans les trains et un
indien de plus mais les nord la paire de
fou on a quand même un peu ouvert le jeu
alors attention dans ce type de position
aussi classique
on peut aussi avec les noirs envisagée
alors peut-être des coups comme
cavaillon 5 qui sont résumées cavaliers
c'est possible des coups comme tour g8
ici aussi puisqu'on a ouvert cette
colonne on peut jouer tour g8 avant de
sortir le fou peut-être pour commencer à
poser une question sur g2 activer la
tour aussi qui pourra peut-être entrer
en jeu par un g4 pourquoi pas viser et
puis on est quatre gars né il ya plein
d'idées ici pour les noirs pour ouvrir
le jeu profiter de ça et aussi tôt ou
tard pour jouer avec les noirs b6 b6
forçant les noirs à prendre on pourra
peut-être prendre b4 plutôt que
reprendre mes 6 et le fou surtout de
fouet puis tu vas jouer puisque on
enlève des pions et il va encore plus de
jeu donc c'est dangereux mais c'est
envisageable et hills aurait pu être
dans le style de carsen de faire ça mais
il joue un coup plus solide
positionnement vous allez voir son idée
encore plus simple c4 menace d'aller
prendre des 5 et après d'en prendre en
prend pions prend on a isolé les pions f
cet epci ce doublé est là avec un
avantage blanc certains jeux en finale
même la paire de fou n'est pas un
critère suffisant pour justifier des
pions aussi faible on peut pas laisser
avec les noirs faire ça il faut
absolument reprendre ses 4 c'est ce que
fait carrière
voilà on reprend en c4 et la regarder
tranquille où le car celle la veille des
deux voilà bien sûr on veut reprendre en
ckd du cavalier de façon à sortir ses
pièces ici noah aurait pu tenter le coup
peut-être ces trois cas l'air
intéressant on peut regarder ça l'idée
c'est quand on est un pion perdu comme
ça autant essayer de casser la structure
adverse les blancs pas le temps de faire
grand chose ici sur goulon peut changer
prendre b2 on a gagné un pion donc il
faut pas d'un an on est obligé de
reprendre ces trois et on a un peu
affaibli on peut dire quand même un
petit peu les pions blancs et donc ça a
l'air quand même intéressant donc je
sais pas pourquoi quelqu'un qui ne fait
pas ça il choisit de reprendre tout
simplement c5
bon pourquoi pas ces trois équipes
étaient de plus près si finalement que
reprendre mais il oblige les blancs a
peut-être entre guillemets perdant temps
en reprenant ses quatre aussi parce que
si on joue ces trois on a déjà repris le
pion après pions prend faut penser 5 c
aux blancs de jouer alors que la cnds il
faut quand même reprendre le pion c4
tools tard mais ils se pressent pas car
ce n est rien et il fait d'abord cavale
f3 il sort ses pièces il veut rockets
perd pas de temps ce pion de toute façon
il le prendre quand il veut donc ici
petit rock quand même des noirs donc on
joue pas sur la colonne jay puisque
sinon le roi ont été serait resté au
centre le vois mal faire le grand roque
alors que les lignes sont ouvertes de ce
côté là si le noir les nord-africains
rock ont regardé la colonne s'est
ouverte ici évidemment une tour sera
ravi de se mettre en face du roi tôt ou
tard et ça peut être effectivement être
vraiment dangereux on peut quand même du
côté où on a les phobiques étions
faibles mais les blancs n'ont pas de
quoi aller attaquer cette structure
c'est extrêmement quand même solide un
temps qu'on bouge pas ce cette petite
masse de piau on a quand même contrôle
de cases tout à fait important et blanc
n'ont pas de quoi aller attaquer donc
ils rock aussi et il n'y aura pas
d'attaqué
là maintenant car il ya 5 alors
attention on me l'a dit tout à l'heure
on peut aussi s'accrocher à ses pions un
garde est donc là on s'accroche
les calices et 5 avaya celle qu'on
s'accroche aux pions c4 un petit peu
même si les blancs peuvent reprendre
tous cavaliers en attaque mais bon qu'on
menace un petit peu de décès de
s'accrocher on pourrait ici on menace
peut-être a6b scène pour gagner du temps
à 6 obligerait à prendre du fou on peut
se jouer dès 5 ans 8 soit prendre le fou
et ensuite jouer b5 pour te mettre le
fou en bessette avec deux coups
magnifiques et qui compensent largement
le pion doublé 1 autour s'est
tranquillement pour qu'arsène qui
rajoute de la pression sur la colonne il
prend quand il veut en c4 et
bon il continue à développer ses pièces
comme se pressent pas développe et la
carabine joue le couffo 7 alors fawcett
jeudi passé pas c'est quand même pas un
coup qu'on a vraiment je n'ai pas envie
de jouer mais bon il revient à la maison
après avoir pris là toujours pas fini
son développement concret doivent se
dire qu'ils craignent pas grand chose
pour l'instant c'est vrai que bon les
blancs mais qu'ils soient bien
développés n'ont pas non plus de menace
directe bourgeois hausse est aussi bon
garde un oeil sur f6 en cas de cavaliers
ou quatre qui tend même peut être dans
l'idée qu'il n'ya pas m6 qui a attaqué
parce que sinon regardez le avec le foin
c5 on aurait pu tout cas eu 4 est menacé
d un échange de dames et la prison et
s'ils sont avec échec donc là ça marche
pas donc mme fawcett
on ne peut pas moi protéger et 6 à noter
aussi qu'on déblayent un peu la colonne
c'est donc en cas de sortie des noirs
par food et s'est ensuite très vite une
tour pour y venir assez vite et à la fin
on protège ses pions donc il faut quand
même pas laisser faire non plus dams et
de voile adams et 2
il évite le vis-à-vis des dames lille et
tours voilà tranquille un carsen rail se
pressent pas vraiment pas et afu 17 afin
qu'ils se dépêchent maintenant de finir
son développement food et c'est très bon
coup juste à temps parce que sinon
l'autre tour revenir en d1 et surtout 17
ici on aurait pu sortir le cavalier et
on aurait cloué le fou ici regardez la
tour et attaquer la dame
avec le fou 17 cloud et ça aurait été
très très embêtant donc il le fait au
bon moment un sou 17 et en même temps il
peut menacer derrière ciblant faut pas
attention attention toujours séduite
attaquer ici faire protéger ses 4 blanc
des problèmes qu'il faut reprendre ce
pionnier quand même pour l'instant rien
de moins ils peuvent le prendre quand
ils veulent et blanc mais pas trop tard
non plus sinon ce sera trop tard
effectivement pourra pas donc faut
prendre 17 d'un point 17 et la très
jolie coup de cars scène j'aime beaucoup
ce coup car l'air de rien il prend pas
tout de suite en c4 s'il avait pris ans
et 4 il aurait pu se faire clouer avec
le peut-être des petits soucis
il faut faire attention même c'est sûr
il aurait eu des soucis donc il aurait
fallu dégager en c'est encore jouable de
se dégager mais avec peut-être des
problèmes même très certainement des
problèmes
donc il le fait au bon moment à regarder
un très joli coup dams et 3 j'aime
beaucoup ce coup dams et rompt alors
dame c3 j'attaque le clavier à 5 qui
quand même un cavalier ici le clavier à
saint qui s'y attaquer donc par la dame
qui est un travail qui protègent ces cas
donc si le câble et s'en va enfin ça y
est je prends ces 4 à noter qu'il ya
plus la paire de fous du côté noir
puisque on à échanger et on se retrouve
quand même une petite faiblesse petit
avantage blanc tout à fait le style de
carsen à noter d'ailleurs qu'un coup
comme camaïeu 4 pose un problème tout de
suite sur m6 je fais quoi pour protéger
si ce qui est aussi attaquée par la dame
c3
si le roi bouge mais on peut avoir des
thèmes après sur le roi un deck le roi
des convois bougent ils poussent ils
s'exposent aussi regarder en venant ici
angers7
pour protéger le 6 en cas de cavale est
le cas les noirs pour ans exposés plus
tard un cavalier en h5 échec par exemple
ce qu'avait eu 4 vient en g3 et il peut
y avoir un échec et il peut y avoir des
thèmes dont attention attention
dams et 3 très joli coup très technique
regardez ce qui suit très joli coup de
karuïa keane aussi il fallait faire
attention dam des cinq superbes très
bonne réponse peut-être sans doute la
meilleure réponse
il fallait trouver ce coup je protège à
5 et en même temps et renée j'empêche le
coup cavaliers ou 4 il fallait le faire
parce que sinon on avait des soucis
donc c'est un très joli coup très solide
de karuïa kid
voilà on est au championnat du monde ça
rigole pas voyez que ça c'est très
précis y compris dans une position
sociale quand l'air de rien mais qui
peuvent très vite basculer sur quelque
chose de dangereux donc mais dans celle
c'est le seul moment pour qu'arsène de
faire le joli coup simple d'aller
reprend attention les noirs peuvent
aussi menacée mais d'intention un tour
fc8 où tour à ses 8 et puis c'est fini
on reprendra jamais ce père en est hélas
on a des problèmes clés blanc donc s'il
faut prendre maintenant et vu que la
dame est en c3 y'a pas de problème ici
y'a pas de clouage puisque je peux
prendre le cavalier ça c'est important
tours s'est vite le fait qu'on ait joué
sous ku'damm c3 je prends en étant
protégé par donc a blessé quatre donc en
cas de prise maintenant je vais à une
pièce a donc il faut faire attention ici
pour les pour les noms on peut pas peut
pas vraiment aller cloué au fond
pourrait à la limite il faudrait cloud
et d'en prendre cavaliers on prendrait
le cavaly ses caves de la tour mais on
perdrait à 7 tout simplement les blocs
offrent même pas d'en prendre un pion
prendre pas ça même si ça serait pas mal
aussi positionné lmnp mais on prendre
tout simplement le pion à 7
maintenant on peut pas il faut pas donc
c'est l'heure maintenant tout simplement
pour les noirs de reprendre et après
d'emprunt ces quatre quarts yakine
élimine des pièces attention parce que
le roi est quand même un tout petit peu
en l'air ici on a des pions doublé et
donc il ya quand même un petit avantage
blanc en termes de structure en terme de
faiblesse du roi donc les noirs ont
intérêt à prendre
ils prennent mais après tout reprend ses
quatre petits bilan ici de la stratégie
de carsen
regardez comme c'est très bien joué ce
magnifique coup d'oeil ces trois très
bonnes réponses de kara qui n'aiment des
on est dans une finale puis dan donc
final on peut considérer que c'est qu'on
est vraiment en finale ici et pièces
lourdes bien sûr cavaliers contrefous
donc ça attention c'est toujours un peu
délicat à juger là il ya des pions des
deux côtés c'est ça qui compte deux
pions à cette baisse est due aux fins 2
duo depuis notre côté aussi
avec le fou des pions à deux baies deux
des pions de l'autre côté le fou peut
jouer des deux côtés c'est bien tourner
le fou contre le cavalier c'est bien
c'est un tout petit peu mieux pour les
noirs en termes de pièces mineurs je
dirais un tout petit peu léger mais
structures faibles
donc ça c'est un avantage pour les
blancs alors savoir le bilan de ces
avantages c'est très léger mais il ya
quand même un autre petit point qui est
en faveur des blancs c'est la colonne
sait puisqu'on va pouvoir doubler les
tours les noirs ne peuvent pas contester
cette colonne donc les blancs pourront
peut-être revenir à ses 7 et poser des
grands problèmes sur la 7e il faudra
faire attention la septième avec les
noirs trouve absolument une solution et
les noirs ne peuvent pas prendre l'autre
colonne ici regardez la colonne des
colonnes la fin ils peuvent ils peuvent
essayer mais le problème ici c'est que
le cavaliere 3 veille
on ne peut pas venir sur la casse des
deux c'est la grande différence et quand
on aura doublé les tours leroy va venir
en effet en deux on va bien contrôler
ses cadres les blés noirs pourront pas
pénétrer le gant blanc alors que les
blancs peuvent envisager de payer des
trucks en noir donc voilà il ya quand
même très léger avantage blanc c'est
léger il n'y a pas de pions de plus n'a
pas non plus voilà c'est pas non plus
énorme quand avantage mais il ya quand
même cette colonne c'est qu'à part la
colonne des points noirs qui ont doublé
ici petit avantage bien de fc 8 voilà
quand même on va échanger une perte de
tours c'est pas plus mal
tours fc 1 ça c'est normal tout
reprendre tout reprend et on peut pas
contester
voilà on peut pas contester menace des
blancs pour ses sets alors les noirs
répondent par le très précis tour des
huit
on ne peut pas bien sûr joué tour c'est
cette puisqu'on aurait le fameux nat du
couloir à ça ça fait mal donc il faut
faire attention
et alors je n'aime pas trop le coup de
kars est la suivant mais bon pourquoi
pas mais sur ce point mauvais mais moi
j'aurai du temps dans six 6 mois à jouer
bref un roi et feu en cas d'échec des
vignes blanches peut venir à eux deux
jets centraliser le roi ou est quoi il
fait un coup bon qui est pas mauvais un
bien sûr mais dijoux g3 bon et sur un
cas d'échec mais non peut venir en g2
c'est sans doute pas mais sur ce n'est
pas mauvais mais est-ce qu'on n'aurait
pas mieux fait de faire qu'on nous
réponde
bon c'est une énorme différence mais
quand même soir préféré au fn mais bon
allez savoir
et là regardez si le temps pour les
noirs heureusement grâce à cette
manoeuvre du mat du couloir
regardez comme quoi ça tient souvent un
temps autour des 7 terminé on contrôle
la septième on n'a pas peur de la 8e
puisque le roi par par la structure des
pions a toujours une caisse de sortie
donc la grâce à cette manoeuvre les
noirs finalement annuler un petit peu ce
petit avantage blanc qui étaient liées à
la colonne c'est avec une position très
solide un peu passive puisque bon la
tour étant quand même en défense en 17
il n'y a pas de danger des noirs c'est
très difficile pour les blancs
d'envisager de percer ici il n'y a pas
de prescription passé donc léger
avantage structure mais il n'y a rien de
décisif donc là il va se passer une
finale quand même assez assez tranquille
bref on centralise le roi f5
à noter regardez ici on met les pions
tout sur casse blanche alors qu'on a le
fou de cases noires donc très difficile
pour les blancs d'envisager quoi que ce
soit le cas à lille peut pas les sur
lequel blanche à cause des pions et sur
les cases noires il va se faire attaquer
par le fou bon alors donc évidemment
c'est un tout petit peu embêtant si les
blancs ici envisager pourquoi pas c'est
toujours envisageable un coup comme
cavalier 1,5
si on peut on peut penser à cailhau
scène pourquoi pas attac la tour la tour
et objets quitter la septième pour jouer
ici bien sûr le coup tours en ces sept
mais simplement contre attaque ray
lecavalier
si le cavaliere revient mais en revient
17 tout simplement avec un signal
annuler très vite et si les bleus jouent
aux quatre ils affaiblissent leur camp
regardez si les blancs jouent f4 ici
regardez tout simplement on peut jouer
un coup simple comme fou et 6 menace de
gagner 5
si les blancs jouent tour ses sept pour
aller dire ben c'est pas grave je laisse
tomber parce que je veux la septième en
échange le point sic on s'affaiblit
terriblement après fou prend qui on
prend regardez ici on a des pions doublé
d'accord et en plus les noirs peuvent
tout ça fait jouer ici un coup comme
tourbez scène probablement
hop qui protège 17 et pose un problème
ici sur les pions blancs et en cas de b3
on pourrait faiblir les blancs avec la
scène qui sait et on a en plus affaibli
on reprend quand on veut le plus ancien
que ça serait pas bon du tout donc c'est
pas envisageable donc après f5 les
blancs balle trop le choix il faut
continuer à améliorer la position d'une
oie d2 du roi blanc dans un premier
temps à noter qu'on pourra pas faire
mieux puisque la tour 17 ans de pêche
laurent blanc d'aller se balader donc
issifou et 6 quand même regarder voilà
c'est superbe
alors j'aime beaucoup ce genre de coup
évidemment les pions noirs contrôler les
cases blanches et le fou contrôler les
points noirs en attaque bte cavaliers
museler regarder un comme lecavalier
dominé ici par le fou dans cette
position est la force du fou b3
tranquille où les blancs mettre leurs
pions ici sur case blanche donc le foot
ap dans le vide les jouets bien sûr bref
8 les noirs font pareil sans trahir leur
ont bien entendu il a un petit coup h3
bon là on est un pion sur case blanche
ici bronze sa vie c'est un coût qui a un
taux quasiment d'un coude attend
d'ailleurs le nom font pareil juhasz 6
bon il est un pion aux cases noires bon
mais c'est pas grave le fou à garder
comme le fond de sauce cavalli peut rien
faire toutes les cases noires ici toutes
les classes du camp noir pas les
classements mais 15 du temps noir que ce
soit les cases blanches où les cases
noires toutes les cases sont prises donc
on peut pas on pourrait faire un cas
lyon peut pas bouger faudra essayer
d'aller faire des choses de l'autre côté
mais on voit pas c'est très difficile
d'envisager font venir en d3 peut-être
ans et 5 c'est de créer des petites
menaces mais rien vraiment rien quoi
c'est très solide de côté noir pour un
fer de kalya voilà il le fait qu arsène
il va tenter quelque chose quand même
recette qui a aidé 3 il m'a des ventes
peu la roi des huit des jouets bien sûr
par des écarts yakine qui t'arrive comme
des huit pourquoi avec le roi on empêche
la tour définitivement devenir donc on
libère on libère la tour 17
elle va pouvoir bouger c'est ça l'idée
de avec le roi noir de prendre ces cas
c'est que cette tournée plus obligés de
rester sur la 7ème et on peut aussi
pourquoi pas à proposer des échanges de
toi la finale de pièces mineurs les
noirs font tranquille puisque le fou est
plus puissant que le cavalier dans ce
tube vous
ça compense les pions doublé largement
pourquoi pourquoi les plus puissants
puisqu'ils contrôlent les deux côtés
donc il peut peut avoir une vision
totale des deux côtés enfin total il
peut avoir vu des deux côtés alors que
le cavalier lui vous pour aller d'un
côté à l'autre il faut jouer plusieurs
courts et ça nous prend du temps donc
ici f4 alors lille blanc mettent leurs
clients sont quasiment ici souvent des
conseils quand le fou mais là le fonds
peut pas vraiment attaquer les pions
c'est très difficile d'aller faire le
tour on peut pas et c'est le genre de
coups qui sert à ce qu'on appelle dominé
en 2000 le fou salaires comprend les
cases du fou avec les pions et donc ce
fou bas il est solide parce qu'il
empêche les blancs de man aura et leurs
cavaliers il y les couleurs
complémentaires des pions et ici les
dominer donc il pourra pas se balader
non plus pourra pas créer des menaces
dans le camp blanc h 5 h celle qu'on
peut menacer h4 pourquoi pas essayer de
d'affaiblir la structure blanche ici si
on regarde les tour pourrait jouer
contre pioche après ou tout simplement
en jouant à chaîne pour empêcher les
blues jouent et g4 voilà tout simplement
et il n'y a pas de risque simplement ne
pas on veut même pas jouer à quatre
c'est surtout pour empêcher les blancs
de jouer g4 il n'y a pas de possibilité
on annule toute toute velléité de la
part des blancs à 4 pour les blancs qui
essaie de créer un petit peu une
pression de ce côté-là avancer les pions
avec le cavalier ensuite créer des
menaces essayer de créer du contre je
mets simplement tour des 5
des cinq jeux peut menacer b5
pourquoi pas ici bessèges puis on prend
tout reprend j'ai activé la tour
j'attaque b36 envisageable donc la
carcel l'empêchent avec avaler c'est
celle qu'on ne peut pas jouer des scènes
puisqu'ils ont repris ce tout simplement
on attaque aussi le plan b 7
elle est noire répondre simplement par
messi ce pas de problème est là a
maintenant un cas veille à 6 alors
attention attention attention du côté
noir faut faire gaffe ici on peut y
avoir des trucs alors imaginons que les
noirs jouent quand même b5 ici c'est
jouable
c'est jouable les selles procès de
simplifier un peu pourquoi pas même s'il
n'y a pas de problème ils sombrent pas
sous pression
puis on prend ici tout reprend on
attaque b3 mais on n'a joué qu'avec si
donc on peut jouer avec les blancs pour
ses sets dont c'est cette menace de
prendre à 7 et les noirs ne peuvent rien
faire sont obligés d'aller prendre des
trois tours prat et bombay la position
ici et peut-être un tout petit peu mieux
par rapport à la pression de précédentes
pour les blancs ce que les pions sont du
même côté maintenant donc il n'ya plus
davantage du fou sur le cavalier interne
structure et boire après il ya les pu
renouveler bien sûr mais bon le roi noir
de façon très vite va pouvoir revenir en
g7 ou un g6 où il contrôle tous ses
pions va parce que les blancs peuvent
faire ici à part un coup une arnaque
comme ni pourquoi pas alors donc
qu'avaya si donc les noirs ne rentre pas
là dedans ils jouent tranquillement un
coup d'attentes fawcett à toi fosse est
à noter que la lecavalier a du mal à
sortir parce que becca très pris par le
fou ces cinq aussi ses sept
c'est quand même délicat et b 8 pourquoi
pas alors b8 ça paraît quand même bonne
idée et c'est ce que fait car 7 et 8
puisque je menace cavaliers à 6 échecs
gagnera cette il faut faire quelque
chose
il a tout prévu il joue à cinq voix la
scène et il faut mettre son fiancé cinq
voix la france n aura dès que ce fou une
fois qu'il a finie il tapait dans le
vide ici en c5 au moins il protègera b6
et pourquoi pas une petite pression sur
trois à la fois d'un stade plein même si
ça ne passera pas grand chose cavalli 6
6 échecs bits et les blanches joue
cavalier c'est bon ils auraient pu
échanger mais la finale deux tours on
dit souvent les finales tour sont nuls
le pion doublé n'est pas vraiment un
gros critères ici appelé c'est quand
même très solide aussi qu'il n'ya pas
elle suffira pas pour gagner donc ici
poussé senc pour ces trois temps encore
des petites choses ici roi aux 7
et voilà ça y est carsen rentrer ou
échangés ont finalement là il est
d'accord de rentrer en finale le
cavalier contre fout on est combien il
est serein sur sa position il y tout
reprend on reprend et la callas keane
joue simplement f6 ça va vite finir qu'à
a laissé six échecs pour pas perdre de
temps en dép 6 cas et les quatre
évidemment alors en cas de prise du fou
sans doute après roy prend les blancs
tout petit avantage à cause des pions
doublé branche même pas sûr que ça
suffise à faire quoi que ce soit donc
les noirs de façon ne prennent même pas
ils sont pas obligés donc il garde fou
contre le cavalier on joue au roi des 5
en plus il empêche définitivement la
menace aux quatre ici enfin la menace le
coup ou 4 je peux pas pas on peut pas
parler de menace puisque c'est mais
contrôlée par an puisque table étant
prise mais je veux dire voilà on empêche
à terme on a bien centraliser le roi
c'est pour ça car scène joue qu'avec des
cinq qui veut chasser ce roi par kbc 3
donc le roi s'en va tout de suite comme
ça c'est fait et j'ai dit à toi voilà
cavale et y revient échec en définit ce
qu'est les bassins qui check 17 calais
des katja rien à faire et si tout ça est
très solide ya pas moyen de pénétrer et
donc les joueurs s'initie parties nulles
dans cette première partie s'ils
annulent jolly partie positionnelle on a
vu des thèmes on a une très jolie coup
d'un de ses trois très très joli coup et
une très belle réponse d'amd singes
pensait le moment clé de la partie les
joueurs se sont pas trompés et puis on
peut noter donc cette trompe pauvres ce
qui aussi de carcelle dans cette
première partie match qui démarre sur de
bonnes bases
intéressant car ce n est vraiment est en
forme il joue dans son style d ouverture
atypique dans l'est qui nous mène à des
finales positionnelle complexe un peu je
dirais dans le style peut-être de
capablanca voilà capablanca qui aimait
ça aussi transposé beaucoup dans les
finales où ils avaient léger avantage
voire même des finales où ils n'avaient
pas avantage du tout il était capable de
l'emporter enfin lanka qui d'ailleurs
dont on a ressorti pascal gaulle et on
l'a vu sur fréquence diagonale le
podcast pascal gaulle est ressorti son
grand livre de 1900 1920 entièrement
traduit en français qui a jamais été
traduit un livre magnifique où justement
capable on table commente lui-même le
fameux gambie marshall joué pour la
première fois par marchal lui-même bien
sûr face à lui face à capablanca à
manhattan
c'est livre historique extraordinaire
voilà tout ça pour dire voilà que
capable en cas être champion du monde
dans le style de jeu qui est qui était
comme ça d'être brillant dans les
finales technique se rapproche peut-être
de celui de deux cars scène qui aime
beaucoup jouer ces finales technique
dans des dents ni position atypique
voilà c'est vraiment son style et car
jaeckin et qui s'est pas démonté qui a
montré un très bon niveau de jeu très
bonne réponse à voir ce que va faire car
yakine donc avec les blancs lors de la
partie suivante voilà ça va être très
intéressant de voir ce que va faire car
scène aussi pour jouer face à face à
akari akin avec les noirs donc
championnat du monde 2016 bien parti je
vous donne donc rendez vous sur des
modèles tv pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde 2016 entre carsen
car yakine merci de m'avoir suivi
merci de suivre diagonale télé puis donc
à bientôt pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde
au revoir